hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to those nights of Rachel's
now this is made by the same guy that
made the joy of creation so you know
it's probably gonna be good and this is
also made in the Unreal Engine so I
don't know if it's gonna be fully come
to your new job ah Rachel's ah you sound
excited tronics hey food available at
the lowest prices so you straight-up
guarantee uh-huh this is your first
night at the job will connect you to a
live call with our call me may be your
guide for the first night have fun okay
thank you for a my calling live cold
god damn it hi guys it hello hello hi
are you there yeah hi you must be the
new night guard well if that's the case
which it probably is that I'm supposed
to Elodie with our amazing technology
mmm it's a bit cheesy but you get the
point right
no no well for starters the cop thinks
that putting up security cameras in
practically any corners going to help
man honestly I don't think it will with
what you're gonna have to deal with
but anyway you can switch the security
feed using the click of our standardized
Mouse that the company put out okay
that's one way to describe it oh it's
really old but stud we'll get through it
uh-huh I'm but let me tell you horrible
trees--they with almost every damn what
am I looking at
hopefully by looting the power you won't
be like that by my voice you can track
the power on the secondary monitor and
god sakes to not break it honestly I
feel like I'm repeating myself at this
point power is usually measured through
the closable doors in your office which
can't be closed at any time using the Z
and X key and you'll need to shut them
as soon as something desirable may
appear you probably don't know what I
mean which in that case it's probably
for the better okay
but anyway don't leave the shot all
right a few more things and then I can
set you on your way I actually have a
spare room back to your office ray she's
pretty much been deserted for some time
or we used to allow employees to go in
there but I an accident in there people
say don't ever let those curtains
all the way why not and if you by chance
actually see anything or anyone back
there ah don't go yes yeah oh [ __ ]
oh shoot rough edges the path oh [ __ ]
probably even more than I've seen oh
[ __ ] kasha uh [ __ ] long story short oh
don't ever ask why either
it's just company rule Shana means it I
don't even know myself
you can run fair using the W key oh um
if an animatronic specifically a raccoon
good the thing Goodin's oh god it's two
doors can't hide from them somehow they
have increased awareness possibly some
sort of developing mistake eat it's best
not to think about it too much so uh
yeah that'll set you on your way
oh wait wait wait one more thing if two
of our amazing mtroniks somehow managed
to find their way to both of your doors
that's a big dog a small trick for that
hiding under the desk seems to actually
help and even save my life
I mean my job well you helped me save my
job one time so I yeah close the
curtains ponder the building
oh gosh light I the desk and you'll be
promoted as soon as you know it and
actually please yourself we've had some
issues with our reputation and it kind
of went downhill recently damn pizzeria
down the street fazbear's pizza
something somehow it's been absolutely
destroy our reputation due to them
having some sort of robot incident after
that discovery animatronics may just be
looked at in a different way yeah it's a
bit unsanitary and rude but customers
are customers uh-huh then we either cash
Oh what hello and welcome to your new
job
Doug's and Rachel's yes we have the best
animatronics and food available at the
lowest prices straight-up guarantee this
is your first night at the job highway
whoa whoa what the [ __ ] was all that
what happened why I don't miss some here
Timmy got the [ __ ] hello hi welcome back
to Doug and Rachel's end day yeah um
come I didn't really want me to record
any more phone calls after your first
night okay hey why not after all they
don't monitor the calls after the first
one so I'm safe save
I want uh huh well for starters which
I'm sure you know by now the
animatronics are really jumpy I is way
to say it is something like performing
after hours but bit more but cake it
seemed to actually move around the
building yeah no one knows why
actually uh one of the night guards
tried to do some investigating himself
with which probably was the dumbest idea
ever
yeah something like that it's safe to
say that it didn't end particularly well
huh huh that nothing really happened
recently although I whoa what the [ __ ]
yeah your fourth or fifth night darts
right now um the others being in an
unnatural state one of them even stop
talking and dealt some sort of verbal
communication problem very strange we
had to take it to some therapist and and
we tried suing us cool despite all their
efforts of course it didn't work uh
effort does all it takes to the
companies a little bit of money before
they just wash all the troubles away
okay I shouldn't question it and neither
should you
for the sake of our job at least as
hellish as all this may seem you'll get
through it calls to all of us to [ __ ]
just stop being so subtle about things
yes the wanky bastard I don't know why
these are still closing that was like a
million hours of conversation that I
didn't need to talk about there's so
much information that they just threw me
how am I supposed to be able to counter
behind all of it it was all wrapped up
in an enigma with [ __ ] about how man
died
the [ __ ] there's a load of bull shy who
the [ __ ] are you with your green glowing
outlast [ __ ] eyeballs thank you
who the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] that
doesn't sound good
get the [ __ ] out of here then the crunch
rolls I don't know the controls yeah why
don't you put away the controls ah okay
I just need to get that panic out of my
system so that I was able to actually
comprehend what that what was going on
here it's already 3 a.m. everything
seems to be [ __ ] and horrible what
the [ __ ] I this threw me into the deep
end of the pool faster than I've ever
been thrown in my goddamn life you would
like holy [ __ ]
oh my god ok so now that I'm done
panicking let's actually try to do
something about this and close these
goddamn curtains whatever the hell it's
gonna be popping out of the goddamn
curtains how am I supposed to be able to
know anything and I can't even keep
track of what's coming down the hallways
like I don't know missing one one is
definitely missing ones over there but
there's another one that's metal I don't
know what's popping out of there I had
to listen to a phone call for about ten
[ __ ] minutes which is fine I get
Becket back story needs to be put out
there but I don't remember like they
were telling me hints on how to hide and
when to go back and the only thing I
remember is go back to the goddamn
curtains so that I can close them for
some [ __ ] reason
and then go about my goddamn life which
I don't understand fully yeah man when I
got the most snarky boss that ever
existed in the world of [ __ ]
animatronic [ __ ] here I haven't even
seen a goddamn animatronic we're putting
it out like I'm gonna die in two goddamn
seconds but nothing has attacked me Oh
what the [ __ ] what was that
hello but I don't know what once this
gets further in the nights how am I
supposed to be able to get all the way
to the back here and be able to close
this [ __ ] and then go up all the way
to the front oh [ __ ] what was that sorry
I'm in just a bit of a tizzy so I'm
hoping that everything's gonna be okay
I got power to waste so I'm pretty sure
yeah it's almost 6 a.m. so well alrighty
then
oh ok right
so there's just like that I don't know
if there was something bugged about the
first nighter just because the phone
call went on so long but it seemed like
it seemed to like cut him off when those
very vital information and I'm already
on the third night what the hell doesn't
make any sense it was like no threat yet
what the hell happened I am so confused
I'm so confused
oh no terrific taking the endoskeletons
was enough wait oh [ __ ] what uh hello
sorry about that just accidentally pick
up at the wrong moment Oh welcome back
to Rachel's of course by now I'm sure
you have to hang on things so there's
absolutely of rambling on I'm actually
just surprised you lasted this long I
mean with your job yeah Piggy's going
anyways I've heard some news lately
nothing interesting of course you know
accept the fact that the owner is
missing weirdly no one has seen him
anywhere in the building bit strange I
think not that I really care
curiosity you know yeah you want to know
the worst part we won't get promotions
without it being here I uh hopefully
wishi comes back for the sake of the
promotion it's stupid to think of
getting the promotion by now they're way
enough probably due to the fact that the
owner doesn't really want to be attached
to the company or the mascots for some
reason maybe he hates this much food
whatever reason maybe as much as we do
there are many ways that you probably
not ever imagine this place sure doesn't
a shady past all right so I think I'm
gonna call it quits now chat with you
tomorrow
let's see yeah yeah if I'm gonna be here
tomorrow they're all off the stage and I
can't even find him on the [ __ ]
camera let's see oh hey how's it going
that is nearby to me isn't it oh [ __ ]
but that's another door I don't even
know what that door is so comes to the
left how do I do that what'd I do what
the [ __ ] I do I don't understand any of
this [ __ ] huh it's gotta close
whatever the hell this curtain is what
was that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh hi hi hi hi
hi hi hi oh hi
Oh last piece of crap bullying big
friends boy they're gonna hang out with
the dog in the house what is that a cat
I have no idea
oh man
[ __ ] me yeah what is with the curse what
is with any of this in this game man oh
boy
I'm gonna close at least one of these
doors just because it seems like I got
more than enough power to be able to
last through the day
Oh what are they doing they're going to
the raccoons Hut why I did not know that
was a raccoon in there but I'll take
your word for it and this guy is getting
awfully close to me okay yeah there's
three door oh that that's the back room
on the right there okay so he's coming
up the okay so I I'm gonna close the
other door cuz yeah he's not coming down
that way I should probably check on the
back area okay that was pretty wide open
I need to be more mindful of that jeez
jeez okay he's moved where did he move
to are you all pal oh [ __ ] me
I don't understand I don't get it what
the hell just happened one I know know
what the [ __ ] I don't I have no idea oh
man
okay I'm gonna end this episode here
because this is bizarre they threw so
much information so quickly I have no
idea what to do that is this and what's
weird is that it seemed like nothing was
happening it was very hard to get a wrap
on there was so many different things to
do it was impossible to get a grasp on
anything and yet nothing was attacking
me for two nights straight what the [ __ ]
I don't get it Wow
something I need to wrap my head around
this I'm an N this here let me know what
you think in the comments below thank
you everybody so much for watching now
as always I will see you in the next
video
I